moi ma personnalité c'est pas du tout
comme ça j'aime profiter l'affût d'un le
kif
c'est un poil en titre électro
lemmy schaller je n'avais pas vu
koh-lanta sauce et ojla mais est ce que
alain ce n'est pas moi esclave à votre
époque y avait des cordées qui était
plus stable pour la bronzette que pour
le pôle aventure non mais après faut
voir moi je le vois ils sont super
fatigué ça fait six jours là qui sont
sur l'île ont rien à manger et le début
c'est plus difficile que la fin voilà ne
se repose
pourquoi c'est plus difficile au début
qu'à la fin parce qu'au début on a du
mal à s'adapter et plus les jours
passent mais on s'adapte sur l'île c'est
simplement vous ai pas découvert un kilo
sur la journée par la suite aux
aventures 18 18 kg et les a jamais
repris un an combien de jours on dans
les débuts de koh lanta vous avez
compris il ya ceux qui saccade sac
thématise s'acclimate à l' aventure et à
ceux qui ne s'étaient même pas qu'ils
ont des problèmes généralement ça se
passe au niveau du ventre et de la
décence ça se passe pas très bien où est
la vraie candidate à refaire les frais
et bien c'est alizé a dit si l'on ne
sent pas bien du tout parce que ses
docteurs pour mohamed
alizée a est toujours très mal à son
état s'est aggravé et elle aimerait la
consultation du médecin s'il vous plaît
alizée à trouve affaibli comme le fap n
1 pour être honnête ça pourrait pas
petite soeur super souriant sur le corps
mais là on a sorti depuis ce matin que
physiquement là
l'accusé s'était bien comporté alors
chris christie champion de kitesurf ici
format du monde umed miles à 66 km heure
auxquels s'adonneraient bravo et vous
avez mis un à wes alors là vous avez
vous avez vous avez massacré le problème
c'est que dans cette émission on parle
d' équipe départ il ya trois équipes si
je me dis allez aussi ouais mais jaune
et rouge lé est en réalité c'est que
l'individuel
ouais on parle d' équipe il ya trois
équipes tout le monde se tire dessus
on passe des fois d'une équipe à l'autre
et au final je comprends pas en fait le
concept entre le côté on vante le côté
l'équipe donc normalement on s'entraide
et puis en réalité une stratégie
complètement l'individuel qui fait
partie du jeu donc c'est pas la diren
c'était une bonne idée de faire trois
équipes toc 2 oui pour changer un peu
oui je pense que c'est bien sa parole de
l'émission c'est commenter quand même
mais il a complètement raison
enfin on nous vend ça comme une très
belle émission d' aventure c'est le
festival des risques ineris et le
festival des mesquineries tout le monde
parle sur tout le monde il y en a pas un
qui est content pour l'autre il dit
c'est ma petite soeur et a prédit doit
le rester dans ce travail est une
réalité
non mais lorsque je viens voir la clé il
ya les potées hausser leur hebdo
d'hazard mais raymond donc donc soit
honnête dans une émission individualiste
où chacun pense à sa gueule et envie de
gagner les 100 millions début est réduit
à des équipes et le but c'est de pas
perdre mon de son équipe du cours n'est
ni quiz sur l'épreuve sur le che merguez
moi j'ai compris l'expression tuer père
et mère pour y arriver c'est là bas
qu'il faut aller aux bleus mais qu'il
soit il fait du feu je me sais faire du
feu victor ils ont éliminé non ils sont
non seulement gérer ça il ya une
histoire amusante avec victor faisait
que là-bas dans koh lanta il pêche ils
ont raison car pendant qu'un des
candidats qui va à la pêche équipage à
poissons ça c'est déjà le regard partie
de cette histoire regarder
[Musique]
les voies sans donner la
ben ali
je suis content que ce soit alexandre
qui chez le poisson le premier poisson
est ce que ça montre aussi que lui comme
moi on est aussi des aventuriers alors
j'ai pas combinaison dans l'équipe mais
là le poisson la 6éme est à doute c'est
pas mal quand marin de ski mais on sait
que victor qui a vu que dota et pêcher
un poisson il dit moi aussi je vais
pêcher un poisson
sauf que regarder ce qui s'est passé
c'est bien certaine maturation victor
qui s'est en fait ça me surprend pas
trop parce que je pense qu'il était un
peu énervé ou vexé soit moi qui ai fait
chier c'est grave de pas être le premier
vous entraîner pour qu'ils apprennent à
leurs prix et tout mais je pense qu'il
est alors ça c'est le victory pas avec
son petit fusil de chasse à peu près
c'est un poisson sauf que comme il
trouve pas de poisson c'est une branche
à saumane va te mentir mais qui va
prendre un poisson dans le filet mais le
fils il est commun un regard victor bon
sa réaction était un peu étrange c'est à
dire que il est ce besoin impératif de
sa tribu tout avec ma petite canne à
pêche au calme
[Musique]
regarde comme les temps il peut avoir ce
côté agaçant forcément
il vient pour c'est moi qui posais les
filets de pêche hier donc c'est grâce à
moi m qu'il fasse gaffe que son mauvais
caractère ne prennent pas le dessus sur
la sympathie qu'on a sur lui
[Applaudissements]
cette émission c'est le pire qui ressort
de chacun forcément il ya des conditions
assez difficiles donc difficile de voir
le meilleur et la poésie parce que
cheikh dans le démarrage c'est le
meilleur sur tille chaque nom risque